[Music]
as we continue to mark one year since
the deadly january 6th attack we want to
look at the historical significance of
the storming of our capitol building
according to a recent cbs news poll
68 68 of americans more than two-thirds
believe that that attack was a sign of
increasing political violence to come
only a third saw it as an isolated
incident joining me now are cbs news
political contributor joel payne and cbs
news chief political analyst john
dickerson uh good morning to both of you
uh i'm very glad you're here to provide
some depth uh and some background to
what got us here joel i want to begin
with you we're at a moment politically
in this country where the two sides
don't just think the other side is wrong
they think the other side is a threat
immoral even how did we get to that
point how do we get out of it there's so
many root causes i think the interview
that you did with the two voters earlier
i think indicate some of those
institutional breakdowns right belief in
media belief in government those things
have all gone by the wayside over the
last two decades also when you just
consider the fact that thinking about um
you know january 6th so many
voters feel like every election is a
life or death event
they feel like if i lose if the other
party wins it means doom for me and i
think that is spell doom for our
democracy yeah john we are at a point
where it doesn't seem like there's a
referee in american life you know people
don't trust congress they don't trust
the courts they don't trust the media so
so who can step in but you also hear
people say hey we've had political
violence before how is this different
you know the to the referee point a lot
of american democracy relies on us to be
our own referees and what we've learned
on january 6th is is that when you
forget about all the the traditions and
rules that were sort of more agreements
when you let all those drop you allow
violence to rush in if you think about
political violence in america there was
a period where you showed you were a
partisan by fighting in the streets so
we have had that before and before the
civil war obviously but then even in the
in the 60s but that's not to say that
we've seen this before what was
extraordinary about january 6 is you've
never had a person of such high
political power you can't get any higher
than the president take such direct aim
at right at the heart of democracy and
what is the heart of democracy that you
can peacefully transfer power and that's
what president trump tried to undermine
both by inciting the rioters but also in
what he tried to do with the department
of justice in getting the the votes
overthrown and also what he tried to do
in the states and john what's
interesting is that if you look for the
first reference to a stolen or illegal
vote in the career of donald trump as a
politician it's the iowa caucus and then
as recently as last month press releases
again referring to a stolen election i
have a caucus in 2016 that's right and
then he said it in general election
consistently about the in 2016. so this
has been something
you know part of what january 6 was is a
lot of gasoline was thrown on the floor
and as you point out it was four years
before
even the event here and that gasoline
started to accumulate and part of that
also includes the idea that basically as
joel was talking about earlier that the
the when that the opposition was not the
opposition it was the enemy and that if
you dehumanize them once you dehumanize
them enough well then anything goes and
that's what we saw here so joel
when donald trump goes away or leaves
the stage of public life
is this all over does the threat recede
well fortunately not also when you think
about the individuals who are here last
january 6th these yes there were
everyday americans there were also
office holders people who are running
for office i think i saw a report that
nearly three dozen of those people maybe
even more are actually running for
office so you're talking about
individuals that took this ultimate act
who are going to be at the levers of
power and also the republican party has
gotten more extreme they have not backed
off there's no political incentive for
them to back off of their january 6th
position
do you want leaders to lead more or do
you have hope that these voters are
going to in their communities and
conversations amongst themselves come to
a different conclusion about the
country's future so this is a thing in
politics that i think we've always
struggled with is do the people lead the
leaders of the leaders lead the people
and i think in this situation you need
leaders who have guts to stand up it was
tough for mitt romney it was tough for
lindsey graham when they were harassed
at airports last year they've got to
have the gumption to deal with that to
push back on their voters and say this
is wrong they've got to have their own
john mccain moment like he had in 2008
on the campaign trail as karl rove
writes about in the wall street journal
today karl rove who's no shrinking
partisan he says the republicans have a
heavier burden when talking about
january 6. there were denunciations on
january 6th a year ago but a lot of
those have slipped into the background
and his argument is that republicans
need to be as clear today as they were
then about the fact that this was a
criminal terrorist attack that it was
incited by donald trump and that the
republican party can't survive if it has
truck with that [ __ ] yes the fbi is
investigating this as a domestic
terrorist incident to your point uh
gentlemen thank you both we appreciate
it